taxing the rich here's the deal everyone
knows what happened last night aoc went
to the met gala thirty thousand thirty
five thousand dollar tickets and she
wore this absolutely absurd ridiculous
stupid dress that said tax the rich and
she did it for exactly the reason why
we're talking about it she wants the
attention so we're gonna give her the
attention no problem tax the rich great
remember aoc makes 174 thousand dollars
a year she's at an event that the
tickets cost 30 to 35 thousand dollars
to attend and literally everyone there
is rich now when you start to think
about this dress taxing the rich right i
get it the medium is the message i get
it that you want people to talk about it
but you're rich
period that's it you're rich you are
rich you are not a working-class
individual you are one of the most
influential powerful people in the
united states of america you're a
politician i was elected by the people
and you get paid 174 000 a year stop
pretending like you're not rich you are
rich now on top of that when you go
ahead and you look at taxing the rich
there's a lot of people who had things
to say so first portnoy i think is the
first one that we have came off the top
rope 360 slam dunk tax the rich but
first i'm gonna go have the time of my
life partying with them all at the most
extravagant over-the-top party of the
year that is essentially a celebration
of richness
nailed it
viral tweet why because it's true you
can't talk about taxing the rich if you
go to a party where literally everyone
is rich and they're laughing at everyone
else in the country saying ha ha yeah
tax the rich and the richest people in
the world are not paying high tax rates
remember we broke down steve ballmer's
tax rate is less than literally the con
concession stand workers at the arena in
which he steam plays so don't tell me
about taxing the rich now next is uh
we've got another tweet here that
is cynthia lumbus congresswoman from
wyoming or i'm sorry senator from
wyoming
and the front must say and debase the
poor right
because if you're taxing the rich
and then you're using inflation to tax
the poor
you're simply debasing their currency
you're doing more damage to the people
at the bottom of the totem pole than you
are the people at the top because when
you use inflation you're enriching the
wealthy and you're punishing those at
the bottom the senator absolutely nails
it you can talk all you want about
taxing the rich but if you simply are
debasing the poor you continue to make
the wealth inequality gap wider and
wider and wider the u.s government has
taken in
record world record levels of federal
tax income every single year since 2011
but we still have a bigger and bigger
deficit every single year why we do not
have a revenue problem we have a
spending problem in this country and on
top of that the wealth inequality gap
has gotten wider and wider and wider why
they're taking all of this money from
those that are the wealthiest in the
country
how is it that the wealth inequality gap
is getting wider it's because of
inflation they are pumping up the asset
prices of those who hold assets and they
are punishing the poor the next one i
think we've got one more tweet here that
we're gonna pull up uh which matt's got
a grin on his face so we're gonna see
which one this one is uh
peter mccormick
actually a much better message by
bitcoin
pretty good uh not really sure who did
the uh the editing there but uh it looks
like peter did that on
yeah i think i think he did that on his
iphone for sure all right so cool you
guys want to talk about taxes let's talk
about oh and this was aoc here talking
about the surge in people looking up and
discussing our messed up tax code is how
we fix it and so we can fund childcare
healthcare climate action and student
loan forgiveness so this is exactly my
point cool you want to fund child care
and health care and all this stuff great
i don't think there's many people who
think that's a bad idea but you've taken
record levels of federal tax income
every single year since 2011. you had
taken more money every year but you
still aren't funding this stuff why
because we're dropping bombs on
countries that we're not at war with and
we literally just left trillions of
dollars worth of military equipment in
afghanistan maybe it's not a revenue
problem it's a spending problem we've
got people who don't understand how to
balance a budget who are running this
country and then we go when we do things
like this where we go we're at 30 35 000
ticket event and we get paid 174 000 a
year and we claim that we're not rich
that's the problem you are rich how do
you think that you are not rich i don't
understand it hey guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today and don't forget to check out
our partner sofi they make all this
possible they're a super app that lets
you save spend borrow earn and invest
all from one single platform and if you
go there today and you sign up for a
sofi invest account you can get between
five dollars and a thousand bucks for
free from sofa not everyone's obviously
gonna get a thousand dollars but
everyone gets something don't say that i
never did anything for you go check them
out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help